[Música]
con nuestra segunda invita al día vamos
a hablar de la onusida no el
departamento a la onu sobre el sida que
publicó su informe sobre las cifras del
vih/sida en el mundo en el año 2021 y
que es lo más destacable marc para hacer
un contexto digamos y ya luego entonces
puedes ampliar y analizar más a fondo
este informe con nuestra segunda mitad
así es vamos a dar los primeros
titulares de este informe que además es
muy esperado porque tiene de las cifras
más completas realmente sobre el vih y
el sida en todo el mundo
2021 un millón y medio de nuevos
contagios de vih en todo el mundo se
suma de más de 38 millones de personas
con vih que estaban viviendo así en 2021
para hacernos una idea esto es más por
ejemplo que toda la población de perú
para hacer una idea de la cantidad de
personas que ahora mismo están viviendo
con vih seiscientos cincuenta mil
murieron por sida por enfermedades
asociadas digamos a la sida de un dato
importante el 54% de las personas con
vih son mujeres y niñas de hecho este
informe pone un especial énfasis en las
mujeres jóvenes y adolescentes de entre
15 y 24 años que sufren una infección de
vih en este grupo de personas cada tres
minutos de nuevo además también los
grupos considerados clave en la lucha y
en las infecciones de vih estamos
hablando del 70 por ciento todavía son
las personas por ejemplo trabajadoras
trabajadores también sexuales hombres
gay hombres bisexuales hombres que
tienen sexo con hombres las personas que
usan también drogas intravenosas y
personas trans todo este grupo de
personas además de sus parejas siguen
representando el 70 por ciento de las
personas que viven con vih en todo el
mundo y pasando rápidamente américa
latina' la región que también nos
incumbe más pues vemos que los nuevos
contagios anuales se han mantenido
relativamente estables de 2015 alrededor
de los 100.000 casos pero en 2021 ya
eran 110.000 casos es una mala noticia
de hecho que no hayan disminuido
deberíamos de estar hablando de que han
disminuido significativamente estos
casos y también 29 mil personas
perdieron la vida en américa latina' por
culpa de las enfermedades asociadas al
sida entonces éstas las cifras que
estamos manejando en este informe de
onusida y precisamente vamos hablar con
luisa cabal directora regional de
onusida para américa latina y del caribe
además abogada especialista en vih
derechos sexuales y reproductivos de
derechos humanos y también igualdad de
género luisa gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de jueves en
directo américa de france 24 para
nosotros es un gusto
muy buenos días a ustedes luisa pues
queremos empezar preguntando el entonces
por la situación general de nuestra
región de américa latina y el caribe
como lo estábamos conversando con más
romanos a la no son cifras muy
alentadoras a por qué ocurre esto y qué
podemos hacer para robustecer digamos
nuestro sistema de salud y poder
disminuir estas cifras
bueno muchas gracias en primer lugar
como el informe lo señala el título es
bastante alarmante en peligro y el
peligro está la respuesta al tel sida a
nivel mundial pero también a nivel de
nuestra región uno de tres países en los
cuales se ha demostrado un aumento en
las nuevas infecciones está en américa
latina y el caribe entonces en realidad
es una llamado de alerta a los gobiernos
de nuestra región de que debemos retomar
el liderazgo que una vez ejercimos para
poner fin al sida al 2030 y cuando tú
preguntas el porque yo creo que
recibiríamos que hay en nuestra región
tres tipos de crisis una primera crisis
una crisis de prevención porque como lo
señalaban al comienzo del segmento hay
un aumento de las nuevas infecciones
desde el 2015 5 por ciento de aumento de
nuevas infecciones en nuestra región
tenemos asimismo una brecha en acceso a
tratamiento que incluye las poblaciones
clave que se señalaban
asimismo los niños y las niñas y las
mujeres embarazadas y la tercera la
tercera crisis es una crisis de
exclusión sabemos que el estigma y la
discriminación
matan y tenemos que hacer más para
prevenir este estigma esta
discriminación tanto en la política
pública como en los programas y en las
inversiones
hola muy buenas muy buenos días muchas
gracias por acompañarnos yo quería
preguntarle precisamente por ese estigma
y esa brecha de discriminación 31% de
personas que viven con vih en américa
latina no tienen acceso a
antirretrovirales y quería preguntarle
qué papel juegan precisamente en una
región donde hay tanta discriminación
contra población lgtb por ejemplo
trabajadoras sexuales qué papel juega
este estigma en la falta de acceso a los
medicamentos que permiten vivir pues
mucho mejor a si uno está infectado con
vih
muchas gracias yo creo que hay que
concretizar en la vida de una persona
como hay hay esferas de estigma y
discriminación desde desde que las
personas son jóvenes pensemos en louis o
en pedro es un chico que crece en una
favela o en un barrio pobre y no tiene
el acceso a educación sexual una primera
barrera luego si es gay
otras en una barrera con respecto en su
familia o en su comunidad si o acceder a
un servicio se le estigmatiza o se le
rechaza es por tanto las comunidades o
las poblaciones que llamamos clave no
accederán a la prueba tenemos barreras
hacia la auto prueba entonces es se van
acumulando las barreras de
estigmatización ya sea en la escuela en
la comunidad en la familia que generan
que por tanto cuando ya muchas de estas
personas
acceden a los servicios ya tienen una
enfermedad avanzada entonces el gran
llamado a los gobiernos ya nuestras
sociedades
cada uno podemos jugar un papel en
eliminar estas barreras y por y por
tanto y por supuesto los gobiernos en
eliminar esas leyes y promover políticas
públicas que promuevan la inclusión y
que eliminen este estigma incluyendo los
servicios de salud luisa también hablaba
de la meta de la onu para eliminar
digamos la epidemia de la pandemia del
sida para el año 2030 qué tan real es
poder eliminar el sida para este año y
creo que nos quedan como 8 años si no
sino que si no saco más la cuenta para
hacerlo qué tan lejos estamos de lograr
esa meta
y la respuesta al vih que ha sido
liderada por las comunidades por los
gobiernos por la academia ha demostrado
grandes cosas que se le han logrado en
los últimos 40 años cuando nadie hubiera
pensado que hubiéramos podido poner a
millones de personas en tratamiento lo
que falta en realidad yo creo que es una
meta ambiciosa pero que se puede y se
puede en nuestra región y el gran
llamado es el liderazgo político creo
que con un aumento de inversiones y con
una focalización una reforma lización de
inversiones hacia la prevención para las
poblaciones que lo necesitan más podemos
transitar esa última milla en esta gran
maratón de los últimos cinco de casi
cinco décadas para llegar al 2030 y
poner fin al sida con una emergencia de
salud pública
yo quería preguntarle precisamente
también sobre esas niñas y mujeres
jóvenes entre los 15 y los 24 años que
representan un gran porcentaje de la
población que se contagia de vih y
precisamente no con estos grupos cuáles
son las estrategias que en funcionar se
ha también debido a una falta
de educacional sexual ha habido algún
tipo de retroceso en este sentido en la
región latinoamericana que pueda
explicar también que todo este grupo de
mujeres jóvenes esté contagiando
si lo que lo que el informe muestra es
que la lucha contra todo tipo de
desigualdad es clave
y por supuesto la desigualdad de género
es una de estas y una de las primeras
herramientas por las que se han luchado
y la américa latina y el caribe en
grandes momentos han sido líderes en
garantizar la educación sexual también
hemos sufrido algunos retrocesos a veces
la política pública avanza en otras
retrocede y por tanto la educación
sexual es clave y la educación sexual es
clave no solamente para garantizar la
igualdad entre niñas y niños pero
también para abordar las masculinidades
que matan las masculinidades que
promueven la desigualdad de género la
violencia de género y también la
exclusión contra las personas de con
diferente orientación sexual orientadas
y con diferente identidad de género por
tanto
si es un llamado a que la igualdad de
las niñas es clave pero la igualdad de
nuestra región también pasa por el
respeto a las poblaciones clave que tú
mencionabas a un comienzo por el respeto
a las personas trans a las a los hombres
gay
trabajadoras sexuales a las personas que
usan drogas que como lo muestra la
epidemia es quienes están más
vulnerables y más marginadas y por
supuesto se combate principalmente con
la educación luisa pero no queremos
dejar de preguntarle cómo ha influido la
pandemia de kobe 19 en el tratamiento en
la lucha contra el vih y el sida sabemos
que obviamente la pandemia de kobe 19 ha
apagado un poco los tratamientos
regulares de las personas que están
infectadas con vih o también otras
enfermedades como cáncer o enfermedades
crónicas como ha grabado esta situación
y como se ha normalizado ya dos meses
dos años después de esta pandemia
si efectivamente como lo señala el
informe en su título en peligro es el
peligro que se puso la respuesta al sida
kobe 19 e imagínense usted en los
contextos donde las personas no podían
salir de su casa tenían movilidad
restringida y tenían que volver a
recibir su tratamiento
pero los grandes retos que hubo en cómo
garantizar estas restricciones de
movilidad no es no hicieran una
interrumpió interrupción en el
tratamiento también generaron grandes
innovaciones
innovaciones que en los contextos donde
sólo se le daba a una persona
tratamiento por tres meses los estados
rápidamente respondieron a dar
tratamiento por seis meses para que las
personas no tuvieran no serán afectadas
por restricciones en su movilidad
entonces efectivamente tuvo que haber
ajustes y hubo impactos no de los
impactos desafortunados es las mujeres
embarazadas hemos visto que hemos
retrocedido un poco
en la prevención de la transmisión
vertical y el gran llamado también a los
gobiernos es que debemos corregir esto
por el impacto de la pandemia de la cob
y 19 para volver a encaminarnos frente a
la prevención de la transmisión vertical
pero también los gobiernos han habido
innovaciones en los gobiernos y el apoyo
a las comunidades que son quienes
estaban más cerca a estos pacientes ha
sido clave para no para no desacelerar
el ritmo